et on va découvrir le chiffre de cette
édition justement pour débuter à cette
séquence 5,1 millions c'est le montant
des promesses de dons enregistrées au
cours du sidaction qui a débuté à
vendredi pour s'achever dimanche soir
une progression de 25% par rapport à
l'an dernier
pour en parler pour faire le point sur
la mobilisation dans le département des
yvelines
nous avons en ligne jérôme andré dans
saura vous oui bonsoir président d'acf
prévention yvelines sur cette antenne
d'ailleurs jeudi soir vous nous disiez
qu'il ne fallait pas enterrer trop vite
la maladie et visiblement le message est
passé
les gens ont été plutôt généreux
exactement et on peut noter qu'il y a
environ donc 25 % de dons en plus par
rapport à l'année dernière
2012 je le rappelle on avait donc le
sidaction avait donc récolté 4 millions
d'euros cette année on est à 5 millions
d'euros alors il faut quand même
remettre les choses dans leur contexte
en 2011 nous étions à 6 millions ce qui
veut dire que entre 2011 et 2012 nous
avions perdu donc 2 millions et cette
année on en gagne un de plus 25 % de
dons en plus c'est quand même très
intéressant donc pour le fit d'action et
je rappelle que le sidaction fait 50%
qui partent donc à la recherche et 50 %
qui partent donc pour le travail des
associations notamment feld achète
prévention comment s'est passée la
mobilisation sur le terrain du côté des
yvelines parce que votre association qui
intervient pour la prévention et qui
favorise également le dépistage a été
très active aussi ce week end vous avez
collecté de l'argent alors effectivement
donc surtout tout le week-end
effectivement il ya des collectes de
dons ça a commencé vendredi soir
on peut d'ailleurs remercier l'iut de
rambouillet qui s'est largement
mobilisée notamment à la gare sncf de
saint quentin en yvelines mais pas
seulement
ils ont fait aussi tous les abords du
centre commercial régional espace saint
quentin et on a eu aussi donc le
disciple des cartes qui fait aussi
démené pour le fit d'action et qui a
fait aujourd'hui encore une
une quête et quand tu achètes prévention
nos bénévoles étaient dans la rue et
notamment à la gare de saint quentin
pour récolter donc les dons des
saint-quentinois et ce qui est sûr c'est
que les saint-quentinois ont été
généreux et en tout cas on a pu noter
qu' il y avait beaucoup plus de dons
manuels c'est à dire directement dans
les tirelires du sidaction que les
années précédentes
une dernière question elle est liée à
cette déclaration de la ministre de la
santé ce week-end qui donne son feu vert
à la commercialisation des autotests
chacun pourra savoir oui ou non si les
séropositifs vous n'êtes pas favorable à
cette mise en état forcément favorables
ont préféré la généralisation des textes
rapide des textes prod ce que nous
effectivement nous faisons qui est sûre
donc du test sanguin
je rappelle en une minute on peut
connaître son statut sérologique avec hf
prévention avec une goutte de sang c'est
un test qui habilitait donc par le
ministère de la santé oms doit préférer
généraliser les filets le dépistage et
la généralisation de ces tests rapides
plutôt que de voir arriver effectivement
des tests donc en pharmacie ce qui est
sûr c'est que ces tests qui n'ont pas
une fiabilité remarquable ils sont
fiables à 70%
bon on nous dit que c'est un outil
complémentaire donc au dépistage
on va effectivement le prendre comme ça
ce qui est sûr c'est que elle souhaite
le sortir donc le sol sortir ces tests à
partir de septembre ou plutôt fin
d'année donc pour la fin on attend de
voir mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'en
tous les cas les gens peuvent nous
contacter pour faire des tests rapides
qui sont fiables à 99 9%
c'est une aisance seront écoutés aussi
un de ce que les coudes fait partie de
vos missions et sont recadrées le
conseil la prévention outre
effectivement le fait de savoir en une
minute
son statut sérologique est important
aussi de parler de réduction des risques
pour les gens qui par exemple ne
souhaite plus mettre de préservatifs
bien orléans les conseils on les
accompagne pour d'autres pratiquent donc
en termes de prévention et c'est vrai
que pour le coup les autotests ça aura
de toute façon
une signification femmes c'est qu'il n'y
aura plus de prévention directement il y
aura donc fait est que les gens pour
vous faire chez eux directement et un
numéro de téléphone j'imagine pour donc
contacter des gens en capture positivité
nous on trouve que l'accompagnement donc
par les associations ou les médecins
doit quand même resté quelque chose de
primordial et on attend de voir ce que
vont donner ces auto test même si on
nous parle de bénéfice risque on attend
de voir quand même merci jérôme andré
d'avoir été en ligne avec ma chef
prévention à vous et merci aussi à
fils de fait mobiliser pour filaction le
dit pas à fait mais fuit les chaînes de
télé n'en parle pas et effectivement on
a beaucoup plus de mal à mobiliser sur
la question du fida effet aussi grâce à
vous et je rappelle aussi le 110 puisque
la collecte de fonds se poursuit c'est
jusqu'au 18 avril si vous souhaitez
faire vos dons par téléphone numéro le
110 merci à jérôme andré je rappelle ce
chiffre à l'issue de ce week-end 5,1
millions de collecter puis cette bonne
participation des événements viens de
l'entendre il est bientôt 18h30 si vous
nous suivez en direct en ce lundi 8
avril il est temps de passer aux sports
anthony rech va me rejoindre sur le
plateau